[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Identity and
Access Management,
or IAM, in Google
Cloud, gives you
fine-grained control over the
permissions that users have.
Today, we're going to
look at group membership
and the resource hierarchy to
understand how you can allow
users to access resources.
Let's start on the
IAM page, where
we can see the permissions
for the different users
on a project.
In our project named,
My Project, the user,
user@tsc.joonix.net, has been
granted the Storage Object
Viewer role.
This role allows a user to
list and download objects
from storage
buckets, but does not
allow for creation or
deletion of any objects.
This role was granted to
the user in the Projects IAM
policy.
So it'll apply to the whole
project and all buckets
in the project.
Let's take a look
at those buckets
by going to the
cloud storage page.
If our user were to go into
the your_bucket_321 bucket,
they'll be able to view all
objects because of the storage
viewer role at
the project level.
As we said before, they won't
be able to upload a new object
or delete an existing object.
The same behavior can be
observed on the command line.
If the user runs gsutil ls,
all the objects from the bucket
are listed.
When the user tries deleting
an object with gsutil rm,
the operation fails
with an error message
that the user does not have
the storage.objects.delete
permission.
So far, so good.
Let's take a look at another
bucket named my_bucket_321.
Here, our user seems
to have options
to delete and upload objects.
We can see this by
running gsutil rm
and seeing that the
operation succeeds.
What would cause this difference
in behavior between the two
buckets?
Here, we can see
that both buckets
belong to the same project.
So our user should have the
same Storage Object Viewer role.
The user should have received
a permission denied error when
trying to delete the object.
To investigate
this kind of issue,
the organization's
security admin
can use the IAM
policy troubleshooter.
Let's head to the IAM and
Admin page and then click
on Policy Troubleshooter.
Here, you'll be
able to see details
on what permissions a user has.
We can put in our user's
email, the full resource
path, and the permission
we want to investigate.
If you want to see more details
about Policy Troubleshooter,
check out the documentation.
After we click
Check API Call, we
can see that the user has
the Storage Object Admin
role at the bucket
level due to being
a part of the
group@tsc.joonix.net group.
Storage Object Admin lets users
do more than just view objects.
They can also create
and delete them.
Even though the user
has the viewer role
on all buckets in the
project, having the admin role
on this specific
bucket overrides that.
In order to use the
policy troubleshooter,
you'll need to have the
ability to see policies
across the organization, such as
with the iam.security reviewer
role.
You also need access to
see group memberships
for any groups that you
want to list users for.
Check out the
documentation to see more
about using the Policy
Troubleshooter and which
roles you'll need.
[MUSIC PLAYING]